Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jonathan
from its north, something I can't cut off
Jonathan from North. Where are you from, Jonathan?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Great to talk to you,
first of all. I'm from North Carolina.
OK, I'm actually from close to Charlotte.
Beautiful. My question was regarding.
People who have sort of undergone a bit of a
change ever since Trump went into office. Yes.
For me, it's a little personal
because my mom is kind of like
add like a complete personality change.
Hmm. And. My question is sort of, I guess.
What do you think in the next five to 10 years
like? Will be the impact of so many people having
this complete 180 about their viewpoint
of life, like how will that affect
the way that the rest of the country kind
of reacts because we can definitely see,
like there's a lot of people who
that really have have that, but
I don't even really know how to put it
into words like just there's there's a
lot of people who have it's completely changed.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they're off the deep end. I mean,
here's the thing, so let me give you
the worst case, and then we'll give you
the optimistic. The worst case is that the sequel?
Over the next ten years of these newfound radical,
reactionary Trumpist types is going to be
disastrous for the country because increasingly
they're going to be, you know, the teachers in
schools. They're going to be the people deciding
what gets taught and how in schools they're
going to be. I guess some nurses and doctors,
they're going to be elected officials. And
that is absolutely horrifying. And that's the
pessimistic case. And that's why we need to,
even absent Trump, remain extremely active to
prevent these people from gaining power. The more
optimistic perspective would be if they were not.
Many of them were not involved in politics before
Trump and without Trump, they might get bored and
stop being involved in politics anymore again. And
to me, that's a more optimistic scenario that they
just kind of get bored with it all and go away.
Speaker 2: Yeah. OK, well, thank you very
much for taking my question, and I really
appreciate what you do and I enjoy your show.
Speaker 1: Thank you so
much. I appreciate the call.